encore une année compliquée pour les
îles de loisirs après l'année 2020
marquée par la crise qu'ovide 2021 n'a
pas été beaucoup plus réjouissantes à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
fréquentation a baissé de 25% en juillet
et 20 % en août c'est vraiment la météo
que les le facteur prédominant au niveau
des activités qu'en plus souffert
notamment tout ce qui est activités du
père promenade donc les vélos
quoi karting électrique
rosalie les manèges la buvette là c'est
typiquement familial on y vient sans
réservation et en dix ans lorsque
lorsqu'on se réveille et ben voilà le
soleil est là et là le feu lui n'était
pas là donc elles ont subi vraiment de
plein fouet ces problèmes météo à lille
de loisirs du val de seine heureusement
qu'une journée d'intégration d'école de
médecine est là pour mettre l'ambiance
et faire oublier la plage déserte à côté
en temps normal en pleine journée du
mois d'août c'est près de 40000
personnes attendues sur le site en ce
moment c'est moitié moins la raison
principale le pass sanitaire mauvaise
été comme celui-ci c'est beaucoup de
moins de chiffre d'affaires et il n'ya
pas que les accès baignable nous avons
aussi en hébergement par exemple des
groupes qui ont annulé ou qui ne
viennent pas pour des raisons
de pandémie
car les encadrants sont pas forcément
vacciner peut être il ya eu des cas
qu'ovide et aussi il ya une
désorganisation dans toutes les
structures et ça tombe à la chaîne et
l'île de loisirs paye un peu les frais
si je puis dire malgré l'été mitigé dans
les yvelines tous restent confiants
après la pluie vient le beau temps